Che cosa è stato è stata rapita da uno
di voi
[Musica]
an Benvenuti al quinto ballo di fine
anno della Story School in cui
Annunceremo la miss Reginetta della
scuola anche quest'anno che indosserà
questa bellissima coroncina Infatti come
ogni anno andremo ad incoronare la
reginetta dell'anno Spero tanto che
quest'anno sia io la reginetta spero
tanto sia tu quest'anno Grazie Gigo Come
sei carino sicuramente sarò sempre io la
reginetta
quest'anno non come lei la solita
perfettina antipatica m Ah peccato che
non ci sia un premio per il re della
scuola perché se ci fosse sicuramente lo
vincerei io a me non interessa essere il
re di uno stupido ballo A me interessa
solo lei e la reginetta di quest'anno
è
Vittoria Sì grazie grazie a
tutti nuovamente reginetto della scuola
anche quest'anno
grazie E ora Diamo inizio al ballo
scolastico il ballo di fine anno Sì
andiamo lo sapevo come ogni anno vince
sempre lei che sorpresa dai Ginny non
essere triste Tu sarai sempre la regina
del mio cuore Grazie Gigo Oh sei così
sdolcinato che mi hai fatto venire il
diabete e tu sei così acido che mi fai
venire il mal di P Eh ma come ti
permetti basta
basta
mettetela io l'ho conosciuta prima Ginny
e sai cosa vo importa sono io quello che
le sta più simpatico non è vero avrà
occhi solo per me Ma cosa che sono il
più bello Io tra i due Ginny ballerà con
me Ma se non sai manco ballare invece ci
andrò io a ballare con lei Ciao
Complimenti Vittoria Anche quest'anno
sei tu la reginetta Non che fosse una
novità Oh grazie Ginny sono sicura che
prima o poi verrai Incoronata anche tu
ovviamente quando io avrò finito scuola
Certo che sei di un antipatico cosa No
niente Ti ammiro molto eccetera eccetera
perfettina ballare con me Ma dov'è Gigo
Ok non c'è ti concedo questo
ballo Che bella quest'anno la festa Sì
Sono così contenta È andato tutto liscio
abbiamo scelto la reginetta come ogni
anno sono tutti felici che ballano e
soprattutto non c'è stato nessun
problema che cosa è stato da dove
veniva State bene Sì sì cos è successo
l'avete sentito anche voi sì Ma chi
manca manca Vittoria la reginetta Ma
dov'è finita Avete visto dov'è andata io
c' ho parlato poco fa poi se n'è andata
e non l'ho più vista perciò non lo so E
voi due invece l'avete vista Beh io
l'ultima volta che l'ho vista la la
stavano incoronando ma poi non l'ho più
vista in realtà io in realtà non la vedo
da tanto l'ultima volta che l'ho vista
stava parlando proprio con Ginny non è
possibile che l'avete vista durante la
incoronazione mentre parlava con te
dov'è finita
Allora la corona la
corona che cosa ci fa la corona di
Vittoria la reginetta sulle scale Questo
vuol dire solo una cosa è stata rapita
da uno di voi e ora dovremmo scoprire
chi è stato questo è un nuovo episodio
di Risolvi il mistero in cui anche voi
indagher assieme a noi e dovrete
scoprire chi è stato a rapire la
reginetta della scuola cliccate mi piace
qua sotto e iniziamo subito
l'interrogatorio
ma prima sì se siamo due veri
investigatori dobbiamo indagare nella
scena del crimine esatto e vedere se
troviamo degli indizi E chi può aiutarci
se non il libro Sì con il libro possiamo
Tradurre gli indizi che troviamo ma
adesso da dove possiamo iniziare direi
di iniziare da dove abbiamo trovato la
coroncina della Miss della scuola Ottima
idea sì andiamo lì presto la coroncina
era posizionata qua nelle scale magari
nelle scale troviamo anche qualcos'altro
Proviamo a vedere però non è strano che
la Carcina era al contrario è come se la
reginetta sia stata rapita dall'alto Sì
è stata trasportata sopra le scale Forse
Ah quindi è caduta ed è caduta
all'indietro
vediamo se c'è qualche indizio sulla
[Musica]
coroncina Ehi aspetta che cosa m ho
scoperto qualcosa di molto interessante
qui che cosa Questi non sono diamanti
veri Ma chi se ne frega come chi se ne
frega son diamanti veri costerebbe
troppo Ma noi stiamo cercando degli
indizi Ah ok Per ora si vedono solo
delle impronte digitali
ma credo che siano le nostre impronte
digitali vediamo se c'è qualcos'altro
qua nelle scale Sì Controlla
bene
Guarda c'è un foglietto un biglietto è
proprio quello che stavamo cercando una
parola segreta E come si fa a tradurre
le parole segrete Grazie all'alfabeto
segreto che c'è nel libro
traducete ora questa parola che aiuterà
sia noi che voi a scoprire chi è il
colpevole
Guarda hai capito forse ho capito ma non
ci resta che interrogarli ora per
scoprire la verità e grazie a questo
indizio possiamo finalmente passare agli
interrogatori Sì siamo ancora più pronti
a interrogare i nostri sospettati Anzi
credo già di sapere Chi è stato grazie a
questa parola segreta Secondo voi chi è
stato scrivetelo nei commenti e cliccate
mi piace se non l'avete ancora cliccato
passiamo ora agli interrogatori
[Musica]
via Frank meglio conosciuto come chef
Gnocchetto Iniziamo da te
l'interrogatorio Sì è iniziamo subito
con questa domanda che ci aiuterà a
capire se sei colpevole o no e la
domanda è dove ti trovavi quando
Vittoria è scomparsa Beh quando Vittoria
è scomparsa io stavo ballando con
Ginny Comunque bellissima serata Eh già
è proprio bellissima Anche se mi
dispiace per il fatto che non ti hanno
Incoronata te la meritavi tutto quel
posto Grazie effettivamente almeno una
volta avrei potuto vincere io Esatto
comunque Ginny l'altra volta ho provato
a Dirt la parole e però non ci sono
riuscito Quindi questa volta ci proverò
in un altro
[Musica]
modo Uffa Ne anche questa volta sono
riuscito a confidar i miei sentimenti io
non so più come fare non è che sapresi
darmi qualche consiglio Vitale
Eh ma io in realtà non so nemmeno come
ho fatto a conquistare Anita non lo so
Ma come Ma cosa c'entra adesso adesso Ti
stiamo interrogando perché sei un
sospetto non c' carare di cambiare
discorso infatti Potresti aver rapito
Vittoria e comunque se devo darti un
consiglio devi essere onesto e sincero
con Ginny Ma devi anche rispettare i
suoi dis sentimenti ma mi hai fatto
venire un dubbio Ginny si è allontanata
mentre tu ballavi con lei quindi Ginny è
un'altra sospetta magari dobbiamo
interrogare anche lei sì interroghiamo
Ginny adesso sì Ginny tocca a te
l'interrogatorio adesso con la macchina
della verità e stai attenta a dire
sempre la verità mi raccomando
Altrimenti Sapremo se stai mentendo e la
prima domanda per te è questa tu od di
Vittoria No no assolutamente io non la
odio anzi mi sta
[Musica]
simpaticissima vedi sta mentendo non ha
detto la verità devi dirci la verità E
va bene Lo ammetto non la sopporto e ora
vi racconto il
perché Ciao Vittoria uff ma cosa vuoi
secchiona Io non sono secchiona
semplicemente studio tanto Ehi jimy Ma
perché vuoi diventare sua amica ci ci ci
sono io qui se vuoi parlare sono qui e
che io è simpatica Io vorrei tanto
conoscerla e poi Sono nuova e vorrei
fare amicizia con qualcuno Uffa Ma
perché continuano a distrarmi Io voglio
concentrarmi solo sui miei
disegni Ho un'idea Le scriverò un
bigliettino insom ma è da lì che
iniziano le bellissime amicizie dei film
e tutto il
resto Gigo non è che è per me no lo devi
passare a Vittoria grazie Ok
Tieni vediamo un po' cosa c'è scritto
stavolta da Ginny per Vittoria vuoi
diventare mia amica ma anche no io amica
di una secchiona non ci penso
proprio vediamo un po' adesso
Oh e
bigliettino Speriamo sia andata
[Musica]
bene Ha detto di no e mi ha scritto pure
che sono una secchiona io l'ho ho detto
non sono secchiona semplicemente studio
tanto perché vogli avere dei voti
belli no Ginny non piangere senò Piango
anch'io E da allora mi ha sempre
ignorata e ci sono rimasta davvero
male questa volta ha detto la verità
visto ve l'ho detto io dico la verità
però ho ancora una domanda per te Frank
durante il suo interrogatorio ci ha
raccontato che Mentre stavate ballando
voi due assieme lui ha provato a
baciarti ma tu sei sparita a un certo
punto ti sei allontanata e per questo
sei molto sospetta Dicci dove sei andata
Ah sì Mi sono allontanata per cercare
Gigo però non l'ho
trovato
ma non ha dato la
risposta proprio adesso doveva smettere
di funzionare ora non sappiamo se jny ha
detto la verità o no Oppure no sì io vi
ho detto la
verità Vabbè adesso non ci resta che
interrogare il nostro ultimo sospettato
Ghigo ora è il tuo turno Gigo sei
l'ultimo ad essere interrogato e sono
proprio curioso di sapere che cosa dirai
in tu difesa Sì infatti ho una domanda
molto importante per te per capire se
sei stato tu a far sparire la miss della
scuola è una domanda molto difficile ma
devo assolutamente farla e la domanda è
Tu sei innamorato di Ginny Di la verità
eh beh
Eh non non fa caldo Io ho caldo
eh
Ma perché non rispondi eh Vedi se non
vuoi essere il sospettato numero uno
devi rispondere a questa
domanda Ok Lo ammetto sono innamorato di
Ginny grazie Io io non pensavo non so
cosa dire cosa lo sapevo hai sempre
cercato di rubarmela
rubarmela Ma noi non stiamo
assieme Non ancora ma questo è un
dettaglio trascurabile Guarda che io
l'amavo già dall'anno scorso dalla prima
volta in cui la
vidi
Ciao Ma chi è questa sembra proprio una
secchiona
m dove mi posso sedere c'è un posto
libero tu vicino a me
non ci penso proprio Scordatelo
sei vicino a noi Assolutamente no vero
gco questo posto è libero se vuoi ti
puoi sedere vicino a
me
grazie Quindi tu Gigo Faresti qualsiasi
cosa per Ginny sì fare qualsiasi cosa
per
lei e ora il mio momento preferito è il
momento delle
accuse ora finalmente accuser Remo chi
noi pensiamo che sia stato a rapire la
reginetta della scuola in base agli
indizi che abbiamo raccolto e in base
agli interrogatori con la macchina della
verità ora sappiamo chi di voi è stato e
secondo voi chi è stato scrivetelo nei
commenti Ma ora siete pronti ad essere
accusati Certo che sono pronto perché so
di essere innocente Ah Secondo me invece
sei tu sei proprio tu e Beh tu sei
pronto invece a essere accusato Certo
perché anch'io ovviamente Sono innocente
e allora rimane solo una persona io non
sono stata semplicemente perché non
voglio andare in carcere Insomma devo
ancora studiare tantissime cose Non
accusarla mi sembri molto agitata B e tu
fatti la parte sfigato se accusi di
nuovo Gin io
io basta Basta voi due tra poco
sveleremo Chi è il colpevole ed è uno di
voi e infatti iniziamo subito con le
accuse e iniziamo Appunto proprio da
Frank tu io Esatto Proprio tu pensavamo
fossi tu ma non puoi essere stato tu Ah
perché quando Vittoria è scomparsa io
stavo ballando con Ginny
bravissimo Quindi ora posso andare
grazie Dove vuoi andare vio da Aspetta
non scappare ancora però è vero quello
che dice Vitale e cioè quando Vittoria è
sparita e tu ballavi con Ginny Quindi
hai un ottimo alibi ma ora passiamo
all'altra sospettata e cioè
S tu avresti un sacco di motivi per far
sparire la reginetta della scuola e cioè
uno dei motivi è che lei ha sempre vinto
il concorso di reginetta della scuola e
tu hai sempre voluto vincere e un altro
motivo è che tu volevi sempre essere sua
amica ma sei stata rifiutata da lei e
quindi avresti avuto il motivo della
gelosia per farla sparire però quando
Vittoria è sparita tu eri ancora qua
nella sala da ballo che cercavi
Gigo come perché io perché perché Tu
come hai detto con la macchina della
verità sei innamorato di Ginny e non
sopportavi vederla soffrire Infatti già
da quando eravate a scuola hai visto
Jenny soffrire perché chiedeva a
Vittoria di essere sua amica ma Vittoria
la rifiutava e tu soffrivi per lei In
più oggi nuovamente Quando è stata
eletta la miss Reginetta della scuola tu
speravi fosse jinny ma in realtà no era
nuovamente Vittoria e tu l'hai vista
soffrire nuovamente quindi Per te
l'unica soluzione è stata rapirla in
modo che jinny non soffrisse più
confessa E va bene Ho rapito Vittoria ma
solo per il bene di Gimmy Dicci ora dove
l'hai nascosta subito
anche Eccola qua Vittoria Ecco
dov'era Finalmente siete arrivati forza
Liberatemi Sì dammi subito le chiavi
Sbrigati Ecco grazie
Ok sei libera Oh finalmente grazie
Vittoria io ti dovrei dare una una cosa
che ti appartiene
Oh grazie ma forse la meriti più
tut grazie Io davvero Grazie io lo
sognavo tantissimo di avere questa
Corona grazie Sai mentre ero rinchiusa
dentro la prigione ho sentito i discorsi
che avete fatto alla macha della verità
e ho capito che in questi anni non mi
sono comportata bene con te quindi
volevo chiederti scusa amiche
Amiche
Oh molto carina vero però adesso Vieni
che ti rinchiudo in
prigione
detto
Prione mi vendicherò e vi rirò tutti
quanti
n